مشاهدينا مرحبا بكم في مجزره من قناه
الجزيره افاد البيت الابيض بان الرئيسين
الامريكي جوبانين والاوكراني فلاديميرزين
نيسكي اجريائي اتصال اكد فيه بيض على
استمرار الدعم الامريكي لكيف وقال بيانو
البيت الابيض ان بيض رحب بانفتاح المعلن
على سلام عادل قائما عادل المبادئ
الاساسيه المنصوص عليها في ميثاق الامم
المتحده واشار البيانو الى ان الرئيس
الامريكي شدد على التزام واشنطن بمواصله
تعزيز الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه
وشدد الرئيس
انيستا على ضروره الالتزام بالنقاط العاشر
لتحقيق السلام وفق الصيغه الاوكرانيه وقال
ان الرئيس الفرنسي يدعم صيغه السلام التي
كان قد طرحها في قمه العشرين في نوفمبر
الماضي
قال الكريم ان تجاهل الهواجس الامنيه
الروسيه بشان اتفاقيات مسك مقدمه لما
وصفها بالعمليه العسكريه الخاصه في
اوكرانيا من جهه قال نائب رئيس مجلس الامن
الروسي ان عدوه روسيا ليس في قياس بل في
اوروبا وامريكا وحلفائها
بحث الرئيس ساره التركيه والروسيه
المصالحه المشتركه في مجال الطاقه وانشاء
مركز بني اقليميه في اسطنبول لتصدير الغاز
في الاثناء اعرب منسق والسياسه الخارجيه
في الاتحاد الاوروبي عن قلق الاتحاد مما
وصفها بسياسه تركيا في عدم الانضمام
للاجراءات التقليديه الاوروبيه ضد روسيا
افادت مصادر محليه الجزيره بان الجيش
التركي قصف مجددا تمركوزات ما تعرف بقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه في شماليه الرقه
والحسكه الرفعه بريف حلب فيغلون ذلك اكل
الرئيس التركي لنظيره السيد ضروره تطهير
الحدود مع سوريا بعمق 30 كيلومترا ممن
سماهم الارهابيين في المقابل قال يكملن ان
رئيسين بحثا حلا النزاعي على اساس اتفاقه
شيء
ادينت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه استشهاد
فتاه برصاص الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في مدينه
جنين خلال اقتحامها من طاقه البيادر
بالمدينه كما دارت اشتباكات مصلحه بين
مقاومنا فلسطينيين وقوات الاحتلال خلال
عمليه الاقتحامات عن اصابه ثلاثه
فلسطينيين
فصعد التوتر في شمال بعد ان تبادل مجهولون
اطلاق النار مع الشرطه والقوا قنبله صوتيه
على شرطيين من بعثه الاتحاد الاوروبي وقد
طلب الاتحاد الاوروبي
بمحاسبه الضلعين في الهجوم وحذر منها
جماعه محتمله على بعثته وفيما عقد مجلس
الامن القوميه الصربي اجتماعا لبحث الازمه
دعته الى ضبط النفس
افاده مراسل الجزيره بمقتل شخصين احدهما
طفل واصابه 20 بجروح منهم اربعه من رجال
الامن خلال محاوله محتجين اقتحام مطار في
مقاطعه عنده الياس جنوبيه البلاد
شكرا
[موسيقى]